welcome back to 8701
um in the previous lectures we we
studied how to read fileman diagrams how
to calculate
amplitudes and phase space and we are
able to use this
using fermi's golden rule in order to
calculate lifetimes
and scattering cross sections
we exercise this with a toy theory
and simple examples but we focused on
leading order or tree level diagrams so
in this lecture i just want to introduce
some features of higher order diagrams
which which are rather important
so we started off with our toy theory um
where we um you know have a primitive
vertex
where three particles undergo an
interaction
um the strength of the interaction or
the coupling has
just labeled this as g and then we can
use this
primitive vertex in order to build up
scattering processes and here we want to
consider the process
of a particle a going to a particle of
two particles a going to two particles b
and they do this by exchanging a
particle c
this is the lowest order diagram or
sometimes called the leading order
or sometimes called tree level diagram
so how do higher order diagrams now look
like
here is the first example in this
example is one where
you know one of the lags involved or one
of the particle involves
has a correction to its own mass and
energy
this is the so-called self-energy
diagrams and if you do the counting
correctly
you find that there's five of those
diagrams
here shown that we have a correction of
particle a
but you could also have a correction of
particle c
or b in the outgoing legs and obviously
also in this particle here
the second form of diagrams is one where
you
correct the vertex involved so here um
there's two diagrams
correcting each of the vertices and so
this is shown here
so apparently this changes then how the
vertex actually looks to the outgoing
legs
right so instead of directly interacting
in this right primitive vertex
you have this interaction here and those
two additional vertices here so this
changes
intrinsically how the interaction how
the strength of the interaction looks
like
and then there is a form of diagrams
which we discussed in the context of cp
violation so called box diagrams
where you you know just go around in a
box that's why they're called box
diagrams
and apparently also here you change the
strength of the interaction involved
directly so those are three
varieties or classes of higher order
diagrams and we will see
much more of those when we talk about qd
the week into action or qcd later on
the strengths of the individual
couplings involved in the
particles involved changes in how the
the resulting features of interaction
change
using those diagrams